what's the deal with airplane
peanuts from hilarious moments on kill
Tony God damn that was perfect comedy
right there to NBA legends doing magic
tricks on flagrant it's it's magic all
right what is this these are the best
podcast moments from the month of
November starting off with bad friends
tell you how much I love Filipinos my
physical therapist is Filipino love this
guy he uses all those Filipino tricks of
the trade that you guys have back there
like what he hits me in the back with
little tiny like little sticks with bugs
all over them he says that's from the
home country that's what he says and
it's getting all the impurities out of
my back he licks my feet which I think
he said is a thing that they do in the
Philippines you lick feet well I had a
cousin that they he they said that he
had she had like healing saliva so she
would just like everyone and that it
would heal
everybody so I did make my part up but
it is so beautiful that yours was real
you had someone who are you're she's
like the Filipino Theo Von I know yeah
like someone in my
Village could lick the sickness right
out of you it's insane that's I've never
heard anything like that that's crazy
you're saying the saliva was had magical
powers everyone thought that she had
magical powers because every time she
would lick like something would like
heal right yeah it would heal wow it
like their Wolverine just CL right up
that's insane some kid the know like a
broken arm like come over here like
broke who that's what she did no I look
man I think yeah oh if I the first time
you see uh shoes that's
[__] yeah laces you're like damn look
at these body
tires
I'm black people don't see UF I get so
tired of white people asking me this it
ain't real
y'all
stop trying to make these people real
they not real cuz if they were real the
government would be making them pay
taxes yeah Intergalactic bucks yeah
thank you it ain't real I mean damn
that's I've never heard only white
people see UF fo no I know I know you
think something's bad you think
something's bad now but it winds up
being great later in life like you know
you never know you know like the co was
terrible but then all of a sudden got
soul
Jo's exactly which is like what the [__]
pots Pottsville fck PA has a great
comedy one day you might be uh uh doing
outdoor shows behind a train track yeah
yeah stavos blows past you and you're
suicidal but then you get followers from
his
podcast you're like how did this [__]
[__] blow past me it doesn't make any
sense but later on you plug the special
on his show yeah it's not you get a nice
bum yeah sure yeah you you get a zoom
recorder and you start this whole
[__] thing on the east coast and then
they flip right by you leave you in the
dust you call everyone you know and you
go how did this one get past me I have
fan letters from this [__] pimple
this guy took me out to [__] Honey
Pig and I paid for five times in a row
you just accept it eventually you get
over you start being friends again yeah
and you hope he you hope he grabs his
chest live on his podcast one day and
it's all over and that [__] idiotes
with has to find somebody else you go
you go this is no different than Mark
Norman Sam Marill everyone else d soda
keep going don't don't say the other
one you know it just happens what are
you going to do you are where you're
supposed to be yeah lonely in a room
getting your dick sucked by a guy yeah
one sellout per
weekend all the waitresses leave at the
lake show no big deal yeah they never
want to take a photo with you at the end
of the
weekend on
stage and they have comics on the wall
that have never played
there you eat your wings underneath a
photo of [__] Norman crft
surfing while the waitresses get cut no
B yeah and then you give the waitress a
$20 tip and she hands it back I'm good
you need this more than
I it's fine sure you're more
talented
sure you're funnier it doesn't matter
the fastest horse doesn't win the race W
it's a long distance not a spr it's a
long distance to [__] sadness and
suicide but you'll get there yeah I
think that's a good it's a very detailed
maybe a little too detailed of a
metaphor I just was wearing a red hat
and she's great about Caitlyn Jenner she
was like she said I'm against guys had
some good ideas she against G marriage
she goes I'm an oldfashioned girl I'm
against gay marriage when she came out
against gay Mar I couldn't love a person
more I'm an old fashion I couldn't love
when she said I'm an old-fashioned girl
I don't want gays getting married I
could not love I remember I had rented a
house uh and I was on the beach like
we're M but we rented it for like two
days I was there and I was just like I
read that article and I know that she's
in the area she like lives in Malibu
somewhere and I just like looked out I'm
like I don't know where she is you feel
her pres but I just love her so much for
saying that just going I'm an
oldfashioned girl I just don't want
queers getting
married she goes she goes to a country
club she still kills it on the course
still plays Great Golf that's awesome
shooting like a 70 yeah probably nasty I
think Cayla made a presidential [__] or
no government of California governor of
California it's got to come there's a
great thing there's she's in like a
little car and then like she's going
down some crazy Parade route and then
someone just yells at her like Madam
governor and then she just raises her
hand but here's the thing I was
following her gubinatorial campaign that
I was going to contribute I just wanted
to go to whatever I'm like whatever
events there are to this I'll pay any
amount of money to just go to this let
me just witness this
like up close like I'll I'll just I
don't care if I die broke let me get
near whatever like Brain
Trust is in a room with her like you
know that documentary about Clinton's
first campaign like a famous documentary
like James Carville and Stephanopoulos I
forget what it's called I it's called a
war room where they're all like working
out like the positions and like what
he's going to say I'm like let me get in
that with Caitlyn janner please and then
she left this is what sucks be
California she gave up to be a
contestant on Celebrity Big Brother I'm
like I'm like you don't really care
about the future of California if you're
just going to leave to be a contestant
City Celebrity Big Brother I'm like you
don't need any more money you're already
one of the most famous people in the
world what are you doing yeah that's a
weird move although add it to the
list what the [__] perfect
moves true I'll support never let him
guess your next move dude never let him
guess can you uh could you do an
impersonation of a not gay guy ooh good
[__]
question I love it I've been doing one
for 30
years shut up it's not that funny it's
hilarious let me see if I can do one um
no no
no you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
cannot God damn that was perfect comedy
right
there you guys go I'm in better shape
than you Ian come on are you insane no
I'm not that's nuts I'm not not nut you
couldn't do5 push-ups right now have you
seen the guns have you seen the guns
what are you talking about those are
good gun in better shape you are a shape
I'm in better shape I'm in better shape
sh 25 push-ups right now guys Focus no
no no no noes new new argument who's in
better
shape are you kidding me right now I'm a
brick [__] house Lou you got half that
right Lou yeah there you go he got you
good shut up this is your
fault either bring it to the battle or
get out of the room I mean you're you're
tanking us over here right now I'm in
good shape because I eat at Italian deli
you're full of fish and and stuff Ian
you think Jesus Lou Lou you guys got one
guns guns I got gun let let's play 6 in
stronger shut
up
stop and see what it you look God you're
literally like a you're like a little
rat I'm
awake
Focus God you're not in a maze trying to
get out of it right now
wait I'm not a I'm not a medical person
I'm not a scientist you know [__] right
barely I believe
that oh I've seen a lot I just seen you
scratch and I saw your dick print I was
like
wow oh so you just it
was it was like somebody was giving a
thumbs up did you see it when he
scratching he was scratching I ain't
going to lie about I was like my Lord
Asians really do have small
dick and you look so much happier than
that last time I seen you oh I when your
dick print was so what a dick print
I short morning dick so most morning
dicks get up and it's like an anaconda
in your draws you stretch you like and I
was like Miss Pat I'm a grower Miss Pat
I'm a grower not at 52 sir that's it oh
that's it okay
so you you think you think I have a
small pis I saw I don't know what you
got I don't want to see it I don't ever
want to show you happiness in her face I
can tell you that wasn't it
yeah a thumbs
up you ever [__] somebody say I'm only
here for the car
note I got suck this [__] again is going
to get PA oh my wait wait okay and all
that was making me think of smoking and
also I was like the guy relapses
drinking all the time I was like I'll
just have one cigarette cuz I'm bit
stressed or whatever like that whatever
and in the end I just went don't don't
do it anymore ever again this is dumb
whoever does this is a [__] idiot you
should only be breathing [__] oxygen
into your lungs you shouldn't put
anything else Vape or nothing you should
never put anything in your [__] lungs
you'd have to be a [__] to put
something in your [__] lungs wow just
like I told your that and [__] I'm
never smoking again wow damn and I don't
even want one you when I see people
smoking I [__] pity him whoa I
actually pity him I just go look at that
poor bastard he's [__] trapped or if
it's just she I go oh she's up for very
R this is how stupid I am I went to
skankfest course which is in Las Vegas
right just this past weekend and the
Afterparty was at a strip club and so
right so we're in the strip club and the
stripper comes up to me and we're all
sitting like you know we're at the comic
section and she comes up to me and she
start she sits on my lap and I was like
no no no I said immedately I was like
listen don't I'm I'm good like I was
like I know you got to make money your
body your choice go make money I was
like do it I was like but I'm just not
I'm not getting a lap I'm not looking
for it like I'm just chilling whatever
and she was like and she's still sitting
on my lap and I'm like no it's like
totally cool and then she gets off she
sits next to me she's like what are your
interest like just tell me your interest
and I said to her I go colonial American
history and she was like really like
what and I was like the Battle of 1776
she's like really like who I was like
General how of the red coat Army I think
he's a fascinating character um she
slowly just taking off clothes yeah I'm
like light foot Lee um Robert Lee's uh
who would go on to you know command the
uh Confederate Army in the Civil War his
father the Battle of Brooklyn in August
of 1776 these are amazing battles that I
really like and she's like it's so
interesting she's like I love history
too and I was like oh nice I was she was
like just tell me more she goes tell me
more about the colonial American history
I was like oh Benedict Arnold was
misunderstood and then I started talking
to about specifics of the Battle of Fort
taond dooga and this goes on for 35
minutes and then she's like that was
amazing she was like can I have like $60
for my time and I was like what I was
like no I thought you wanted to know
about history I'm educating you yeah she
was like no a tip for my time and then
her name was Barbie and she go and I was
like what's your name she said Barbie I
was like I was like I'm just Ken and she
was like what did you get it I was like
I'm and I was like I'm just Ken from the
movie Barbie she was like oh that's
right I forgot to made a movie about
Barbie and I'm like
it's insane so I just gave her the $60
cuz I kind of like just felt bad for
taking her time but I was like man I got
GED at the strip club I mean that's a
hilarious story it was also the music
blasting so you're just yelling it Trey
songs R&B songs about [__] women
you're like yeah 1776 yeah yelling facts
and she seemed interested but that's
what strippers do they seem interested
but they're not was she just like yes
anding everything you said oh my God she
amazing she's like I could tell like why
you're a comic cuz Comics have to be so
smart yeah she's just like saying [__]
that she doesn't care about and then she
just got my money but you know just
another woman that got my money did you
give her the 60 for the time I gave her
the 60 for the time my manager said do
not do that and he like got involved he
was like get away from him but I was
like you know what just give her the
money cuz like whatever um so let me ask
you a question Trevor please um how much
do you weigh you guys have been asking
for joke World merch for a long time now
and I'm happy to announce it's finally
here we got hoodies we got hats we got
t-shirts we got FL bags and we got
coffee cups and from now until Christmas
we will be donating one item of food to
feeding America for every merch item
purchased so if you want to support the
channel while helping out those in need
check the link in the description below
now back to the video when you give
breast exams like is it hard to come up
with small talk with each patient not at
all no what about horrible boob jobs
I've had a uh uh someone this was years
ago and I it had to have been back
before they did implants and a patient
went to a a surgeon probably in the 70s
or I have no idea who just injected her
breast with silicone so there were just
balls of silicone like floating around
no like well they get stuck they get
scarred down and she was just you know
she hated it but her husband loved
it I never asked her what voice should
we do the ingredients um could I ask you
to have dialects yes are you good with
dialects some so one of the ones I asked
Andrew to do if I could hear the
difference between his Chinese and His
Japanese you really put your friends in
I mean that was off podcast this is on a
podcast right what's wrong with that uh
I think they get mad at white dudes
doing other vo oh if they get mad
they'll be fine with than 30 minutes
later but the dialect is the Japanese is
slower right so my Japan my Japanese is
just Trey Parker's Japanese from South
Park Oh I thought you were Trey Parker
from The Book of Mormon yeah no from
South Park right but his
is bundoo it's just it's I feel high and
with a camera in my face is it bad to do
this I don't know I'm just high right
now I don't understand I do understand
it was easier on the bonfire cuz we
didn't have cameras in our faces all CU
you're sponsored by the dark [__] web
yes
Chinese
higher Japanese lower
all right I think that worked say it
again wisp no see the car oh Prius now
that's a crisp whip I don't get it
people call their cars whips they do
M well I call mine a Prius I don't think
is it who makes the whip it's a term for
like nice whip like like shoes like nice
sneakers I don't think that's a term guy
I think you might have made that up a
whip do people call their cars a whip
I don't think they
do what's the weirdest place y'all have
been overseas India wait why why why
why India India I'm not speak
on you have that do you need that both
of them dropping their head at the exact
same St wait why why why why why why who
did you see taking a [__] and where what
didn't we see no
look I don't want to I don't want to
disrespect nobody I got to sit that one
now you India is different is different
man been China 10 times India is
different I've been to 30 countries I've
been to 30 countries I've been
everywhere in the world yeah India is
different but why why and it's
everything about it just just from just
from the Stray cows running down the
freeway like traffic you think traffic
is bad here like we might we got to go I
don't know let's say four blocks and I
swear to God it took us two and a half
hours but come to find out it wasn't the
car the tra it was a guy up there you
know a horse and carriage wasn't no
horse just a carriage and a human
barefooted in the freeway walking no
yeah downtown Mumbai
yeah ain't had a pedicure since
pedicures
been I got the zoom in just in
case but man God bless India though bro
it's like why are we all there we were
there for the Kings and the Pacers were
playing a preseason game yeah and we
actually uh the Kings had a ambass they
had ambassador from each team I was
Kings in UHS are owned by an Indian now
yes they are yeah DEA shrimp was the uh
Pacers bassador I got to meet Larry Bird
there that was that was great I how
Larry Larry's great I uh I met de shrimp
that was the first time really got to
talk to De shrimp and I was like look de
I know this the first time I met you but
look that's Larry Bird down there got it
you played with him please introduce
me I'm going whoop your big ass if I
don't so like oh let's right now let's
go I'm like oh I didn't want to go right
now I'm not ready for this so here we go
Larry Larry Bird's face is this long I
me like like so he introduced me to
Larry Bird and he stood up and I'm like
whoa I couldn't think of really anything
to say I said so Larry does does m
remind you of French Lick a lot French
Lick Indiana where he grew up he said
yeah it does and when he said yeah it
does I just kind of lost interest
because I know you're lying through your
teeth Larry there ain't nothing in this
world that reminds you of
moon nothing it's it's one of a kind
it's nothing like it it's just different
and and can't wait to come
back can't wait we did we did do a cool
thing though they had a floating a
floating basketball court I don't know
if you saw Luca dones having some kind
of Air Jordan thing on a floating Court
like on the water yeah huh yeah but it
was it was it was cool but the water you
didn't want to fall in that water
no you don't want to drink the water no
no no no you don't want to really eat
yeah
okay that's what it was that's what it
was they were so relaxed with the way
they handled food and touch food it was
[Laughter]
just my algorithm on Instagram is the
darkest thing that Humanity has to offer
I am now getting just homicides straight
up homicides double and triple like just
straight raight up murders and I'm like
this is Instagram like it's [__]
insane what comes up cuz I'm in so
many text threads with people who like
we one up each other like I found this
one that now Instagram's like oh you you
want of them boys like you want to see
some [__] and so every time I open it
it's just like someone getting stabbed
[__] jumping off a bill on fire funny
when you're high it is so funny when
you're high dude I saw I did last night
I did last night where I was seeing that
kind of [__] and I was I had a moment
and I go I shouldn't I shouldn't just
consume nothing but this for the hour
before I go to bed and I put my phone
down cuz I was like this is so bad so
dark so so wait wait hold on I have too
many thoughts going on right now 100%
certain you were a working girl sitting
on Sunset and I was like man I wish I
had another 60 bucks on
me thanks babe special um have you ever
been with a goth chick yeah yeah um look
at look at the smile on his face look at
that reminisent a it's just not my cup
of tea dang I feel like sometimes the
goth girls are the ones that go after me
a little more cuz I think I got this
goth look to me sometimes I look like I
do a lot of drugs you know yeah but yeah
I I remember we got along really well
like this girl is cool and we went like
on this first date and her clothes was
just so weird she look like a
pirate making my dick off yeah a pirate
oh so she was like I know you're talking
about that kind of goth it's like man
that was good that was her trying to not
be goth too she was kind of like going
for like some colors that thing like
pirate Go Pirate goth pirate goth yeah
oh it's super lame there's the kabad
crane goth too it's like the white the
flowery kind of billowing was she like
super layered up like was a little layer
was she thick she was nah she's not
thick she bracelets tons like 50
bracelets she was almost looking like
Prince yeah too many Ruffles did you go
again Victorian so so we did so we hung
out the second time and I think she knew
that maybe that other stuff kind of
threw me off so the second time we hung
out she just wore like jeans in a
t-shirt uhhuh but now she's not being
herself right which is hot so hell yeah
we got it
on it was a catchy phrase I uh delante's
mom went right can't British Style no
that's just my Boston accent oh okay
popcorn popcorn popcorn yeah but they
say that in Boston that's how I say it I
I don't they say a lot of other words in
Boston I think we're going to go down a
path I disagree with you Kyrie Irvin
over here I just don't think that what
words you going to
say I just don't think it's nice I don't
know what words you're about to imply
that bostonians say but I strongly
especially at a basketball game like
again who is this coming from
Kyrie there's long history of the Boston
Garden well it it certainly back in the
day probably had some racist like most
cities but it's it's I want to say it's
better or worse than any City right now
you're saying Boston is the least racist
city in America no I didn't say that I
didn't say Better or Worse uhuh you know
I'm from Boston I didn't know that yeah
where um
Southie seem like a souie
guy I was there when they called it
Saudi you that that wasn't that funny of
a joke that all your people can I tell
you about my upbringing sure I mean it's
not it's
not it's tough I mean
people no one wanted me I was a [__]
orphan everyone said I was [__] I had
[__] for brains [__] you know I
don't believe I don't believe what
you're saying I had to fight my way out
of my neighborhood okay my friends were
all Common Street toughs and they were
in a gang actually The Boondock Saints
my friend like the movie yeah not like
the movie like the Boondock S I didn't
want to get into crime you know so I
want to make an honest living so I got a
job as a
janitor like so we're going do a movie
we're going to go down different Boston
like what movies are you talking about I
get I what's next I got a job as at
janitor at
Harvard and at night I was cleaning I
saw there was a problem on the board
unsolvable math problem no it said
racism question
mark I wrote down the answer they try to
find me they're like how could a Common
Street tff a [__] guy correct come
up with his answer so they find me so I
was like so you want me to work at
Harvard and they're like no we want you
to join the state police the stadies kid
go deep undercover with the mafia mhm
and then I went home I smoked weed with
my teddy bear Nam
Ted did that go well like no you had
that [__] look on your face if this
was in my office I'd been like enough
this I get thetick it's we're doing
movies we're doing all things I sat here
patiently as you if it was in your
office I'd be on a casting couch what's
that me I used to spend Thanksgiving an
Amish family are you Amish no but I my
grandparents were friends as an Amish
family I'm
gy what is your religious background and
I agree with
[Music]
that I grew up again
no no no not where's a knife I already
did Transformers 4 as a joke why would I
I've already done that what do you mean
as a joke I thought it' be funny to be
in Transformers that's why I did the
movie do you know do you know why I did
it because that's a really funny intro
and Yogi Bear 3D had kind of lost its
like fun yeah cuz that was like your
intro for forever yeah like for a while
I was like ladies and gentle from Yogi
Bear 3D TJ Miller and then that had gone
on a little while and wasn't really
working so it's like Transformers for
that's really so then I would make
people introduce me and go ladies and
gentlemen from Transformers 4 age of
Extinction TJ Miller and once a guy
didn't say age of Extinction and
afterwards I did great I got off stage
and I was like can I talk to you and he
was like what that was great right did
you killed man I was like can I talk to
you like to I'm like it's age of
Extinction it's not Transformers 4 if it
was just Transformers 4 then they
wouldn't have put colon the age of
Extinction do you understand and the
kids like can't tell if I'm funny like
he's like is this guy being and I was
like you think I would say Yogi Bear
without the
3D cuz the title of the movie is Yogi
Bear 3D so I don't is he sitting there
how do I he was just like yeah and I go
I go like this I go but you know what
this is never going to happen again so
you don't even have to remember this
Jesus I walked away yeah you didn't tell
him it was a bit no I keed his
car I'm serious comedy podcasting stats
from November Whitney Cummings made the
most guest appearances last month going
on eight total podcasts including The
Joe Rogan Experience whiskey Ginger
tiger belly the Jason Ella show the
endless honeymoon wife of the party
daily stoic and H3 after dark the top
three most viewed episodes from last
month starts off with Dana White and
Theo Von on this past weekend with 3.1
million ion views in second place we
have Jason Williams on flagrant which
currently stands at 1.5 million views
followed by Duncan Trussell and little
hobo on killed Tony at 1.3 million
please be sure to subscribe to joke
world right now if you enjoyed this
monthly recap and want to stay up to dat
with all your favorite comedians and
just a quick heads up about the brand
new joke World merch all orders placed
before December 10th will arrive by
Christmas thank you for
watching at joke
world that's did it at joke world
and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out